summer officially starts this weekend
joining us to share some of his
must-haves for all things summer is
entertaining expert paul zahn hey fall
on congress
long time no see summer's here though
summer is here and also summer hair is
here i see you have a new look i'm
loving the blonde
thank you so much redken ambassador and
celebrity colorist cassandra kating
transformed me from brown to blonde
using redken the shades hpo gloss
this is a professional hair care service
and what it does is it gives the hair
the subtle
touch of color leaves it super shiny and
conditioned in 20 minutes then
after the salon redken has some great
products to use at home redken's acidic
bonding concentrate range which we have
right here is going to repair
it's going to give that intense
conditioning situation and it's going to
have color fade protection so you spend
all that money you want to keep that
hair that
wonderful color and this reinforces
weakened bonds with citric acid
so we have a leave-in treatment then we
have a conditioner
and then we have a shampoo and the range
is going to provide 56
reduction of breakage and 11 smoother
hair and
do away with those split ends and
everything like that so that is my
summer hair care situation i love it
color hair color
needs conditioning so that's great and
of course we have a summer drink as well
right
absolutely so we have some wine from a
new zealand with brown cotton estate
sauvignon blanc from the marlborough
region so they've been making wines for
over 40 years winning awards and there
are trailblazers in the wine world by
creating this sauvignon blanc in the
marble
region of new zealand this is perfect
pairing with some fish
with some charcuterie boards everything
like that
and um it has some notes of citrus pear
and they also have the flight song which
is a lower calorie wine so if you bring
any of these wines these branch out of
state sauvignon blanc
to a summer soiree you'll be a hit and
speaking of soirees paul we're talking
decor
as well for the summer let's go there
now absolutely why don't you bring some
new life
into the outdoor area with some items
from jcpenney
so jcpenney has such great prices in
such a fun decor from lanterns that you
could put outside
we have some decor that can go inside or
outside with the liberty and sparklers
for all
we have another fun sign here in this
gingham dishwasher safe patio
dining set right here what do you think
of that i think it's so cute and it goes
great with your hair too your whole look
it's all very aesthetically pleasing
it's giving me fourth of july vibes
yep and we have one last item we have
some hatazaki small batch
whiskey so this is a delicious batting
of 100 percent malt whiskey's aged in
imported bourbon barrels
as well as shelly cass in native
mizunara
oak barrels so this has some sweet
cereal it's got some dried fruit to it
so maybe after dinner you can pour
yourself some hatsuzaki whiskey sit by
that fire pit
and toast to all things summer what do
you think yes i am here for
this is why you are the entertaining
expert where can people find more
information paul
find me at paulzan.com all right thank
you so much
happy summer